right sauce okay schlotz mushrooms in a
little tbsp mustard okay this is a
classic state dining sauce mustard in
okay carry any mushroom that's all you
eaten them all what's the sauce
okay now mustard is the pan Worcester
sauce that start the darkened sort get a
really nice flavor
little bit of heat okay and now my
favorite bit the bit that I get really
excited about flambe okay ready
Tommy ACK here we go come over the ends
and into the pan tilt the pan there we
go ready okay here we go
some of the end a summer yeah that's it
let it go come off good we move be
generous come on
Russ stagers lesson
that's fun baby I hope you don't talk
now we're looking for a cream sauce
cream in to the mushrooms and the
shallots okay our classic 70s are true
seriously - delicious cream sauce
screaming good now juicy the stakes in
and place the stakes back inside the
cream sauce yes lovely
Hey nice right Chris yeah
okay now stakes back here make sure you
put those resting juices back in there
okay good stakes back in darling stay
back first of all race your duties ooh
okay and then stakes back in good well
done